Today, we're going to talk about resources, activities, and costs, and congratulations,
this is your last lecture.  By now, you're intimately familiar with the business model canvass.
We've talked about value props, customer segments, channels, customer relationships,
revenue streams.  We jumped ahead and talked about partners, and right now, we're going to talk
about key resources. And for key resources, the real question is what are your most important assets
to make your business model happen?  Let see what are some most important assets?
What are the most important things that are required to make your business model work?
For every startup, the thing you're always worried about is money, finance.
How do you get the company started?  Can you do that on your credit cards?  Can you line a credit
to a small business loan or then physical resources.  You need a manufacturing line.
You need machines.  You need cars.  You need vehicles.  And, how about intellectual property?
Or pets?  Critical to defending your position or is it customerless?  Or should people?
And then that kind of get us into what are the key human resources you need to make this happen?
Is it the world's best scientists?  Or programmers?  Or engineers?  Is there a specific area in the
country that has a concentration of them.  And, so when you think about resources some of these
are just kind of natural.  All you have will hire a bunch of engineers and we'll have a building, etc.
But actually, you could think about the strategic way.  She is impossible to have headquarters in
one place like Silicon Valley, but great engineers back in our country somewhere in Finland or
Chile or Russia or these are physical manufacturing plant that is located in the United States or
do we need to put it in a place for lower cost manufacturer.  And, so all these resources are the
things that you really need to think through even though what they want they might not seem
important.  It just gets to be a bigger and bigger problem overtime.  If you have an actual approach
to this dose of strategy at least giving it a couple of cycles when you start your company.